first sentence blows me away Ryan
coogler became the first black director
to make a billion dollar grossing movie
when Marvel's Black Panther broke box
office records back in 2018. now he's
back with one of the most highly
anticipated films of the Year black
panther wakanda forever he directed and
co-wrote the sequel and this time the
people of wakanda of fictional African
nation are fighting to defend their
country from outside forces in the wake
of the death of their protector the
Black Panther this film introduces us to
the iconic comic book character Namor to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe he's the
antagonist in this movie and leader of
an underwater Kingdom this is a clip
my mother told stories about a place
like this a protected land with people
that never had to leave
never have to change who they were
what reason do you have to rebuild your
secret to the world I am not a woman who
enjoys or repeating herself who are you
I had many names
my people call me
but my enemies call me no more
call me anymore early reviews are
calling black panther wakanda forever
one of Marvel's listen to this best
movies ever say something
saying a whole lot Ryan coogler hello
best movie ever it's so good to see you
good to see you right you must I wonder
how you're feeling if you're feeling and
what was your process in writing the
sequel because you had to change it up
certainly after the death of Chadwick
what was your process and your strategy
in making this because did you feel a
lot of pressure
absolutely
um felt a ton of pressure even when we
signed on to do it again
um we were excited but but felt it felt
a little different from the first time
because people knew what to expect a
little bit and yeah and um
expectations were a little higher
whereas when we released the first one
people didn't really have expectations
at all you know yeah yeah
um but but with child's tragic passion
um
things got different uh it was uh I was
in a unique space I had written a a full
script
um before he passed away I was starring
starring him and was was
very much about his character right and
um and I'd never been in that position
to to write a script and not be able to
go make it you know um uh and so I was
grieving grieving him as a friend
grieving uh my lead actor
um and creative partner uh but also
grieving all of these ideas that that we
have brought ourselves into and then
you're in Los Angeles the premiere was
fantastic just watching the red carpet
and the actor's reactions and Angela
said you know our hearts did right by
Chad but what was it like for you at
that Premiere without him that's a great
question Gail
um the premiere was was more emotional
than I expected it to be really oh well
we had been kind of in a way we had been
keeping keeping him Alive by working on
the film and and when the film was was
ours you know it was our special thing
um and it hit me it hit me like like as
it rolled and as it finished I thought I
wouldn't I felt like I wouldn't be able
to work with him again you know um it
felt it felt final the reality it felt
Final in a way that I didn't that I
didn't expect but but I mean at the same
time um I I know we put our all into it
I think I think it's a movie that he he
would enjoy you know yeah is it true
that you thought about quitting
filmmaking after his death no you didn't
cross your mind it's true but it was it
was um during the shock of it all yeah
um of course uh because when he when he
passed he hadn't told he had only told a
few people what was going on so you
didn't know when you were breaking the
first one that he was Ill no I I there
were signs that that there was a health
issue you know um and in retrospect
hindsight a lot of things
like it made sense
um but but
you gotta understand that dude was
incredibly strong you know um he was
battling that disease since I since I
knew him which was which was several
years you know and uh
uh it it really it really the Black
Panther Family like I said we was chosen
family you know um it was a unique film
and and he didn't tell any of us you
know and he was very intentional the
child was very intentional with
information of course um so I think by
not telling her she was telling us
something that makes sense in the first
black panther there's a lot of gray area
in terms of who was right and who was
wrong on various things and there is I I
understand in this movie as well so I
don't know if Namor is the villain the
bad guy the antagonist or what yeah tell
me what you what you were thinking and
trying to create that character yeah
yeah my co-writer Joe Robert Cole and I
will refer to him as an antagonist you
know
um just just in that screenwriting
language uh you know and an antagonist
is just somebody who challenges your
protagonist you know um uh like uh it's
not right to call him a villain and even
in the comic books Neymar is uh more of
an anti-hero you know
um in some stories he can be the hero of
some stories he can be the villain
depending on the perspective
um but but for this he's definitely in a
antagonist any calling him anything else
would be a little strange yeah let's
talk about Rihanna we can't even say why
Rihanna because it's Rihanna but beyond
that what was your pitch to her because
you reached out to her I'm told
personally was your pitch
yeah I I think um
she has a lot of great people around you
know um Jay Brown especially yeah one of
the partners at Iraq Nation yeah um and
it was really you know talking to the
folks around her because she was in a
position where our life was changing she
was becoming a mom and um and she kind
of had a Phalanx a folks you know that
she trusted yeah who we were in constant
communication with and then they were
going to communicate with her
um and I think the trailer is what spoke
to her the most
um she kind of saw the performances that
the actors were putting down and what
the tongue was heard that beautiful
music by Tim's mixed with Kendrick and
um and then she you know and it timed up
with her you know coming into the space
where she was ready to engage with the
world musically yeah and then we had a
couple conversations and it was just it
was just great it was done uh Brian we
talked shortly after Fruitville Station
before Creed yeah this was years ago
yesterday we were at the beginning of
starting new chapters in our life yeah
sure a lot has changed for you yeah and
rightfully so congratulations
how are you dealing with
who you are now because success is
coming in waves and more is to come
I mean that's external right Nate like
like what you do professionally or how
people view you from what you're doing
professionally like that the internal
has been the same yeah no I'm blessed to
have um incredible wife you know
incredible parents brothers and friends
that I've worked with that knew me
before all of this she had two children
now yeah yeah that's true yeah but but
the truth of it is is like I'm blessed
to have that that family around me and
even my chosen family you know like like
Black Panthers
um the Family Guy inherited through the
work uh uh and they treat me they treat
me it's the same so so it feels like not
not much has changed that's what's up
man well listen we appreciate you
joining us thank you very much
congratulations a lot has changed and
it's just it's really just getting
started at 36 Ryan coogler the great
Ryan coogler thank you so much black
panther wakanda forever hits theaters on
November 11th